hi everyone sal khan here from the  not-for-profit khan academy and i just  wanted to announce our first ever  fundraising campaign on youtube as you  know we are a not-for-profit  organization and we are able to do the  work we do because of donations from  folks like yourself so we're trying to  raise ten thousand dollars on youtube  every dollar is equal to three hours of  learning someplace on the planet this is  learning for you learning for your  family or learning for a young child in  some part of the world that might not  have resources otherwise so please  donate by clicking on the blue button  which is either there or there but  you'll find it there should be a blue  button around me someplace  and please  support us on this mission of a free  world-class education for anyone  anywhere thank you  you